well let's talk to the shadow foreign
secretary lisa nandy good to see you
this morning
so grant shap says the labour party is
obsessed with all of this when you
should be focusing on
well the pandemic for a kickoff well we
are focused on the pandemic but we also
want to know that we have a prime
minister
in this country who puts the interests
of the british people first and the
problem
with what has gone on over the flats is
that we still don't know who
loaned the prime minister this money he
won't even confirm or deny
whether it was loaned or not we don't
know why he didn't declare it and we
don't know what he
offered them in return the reason that
those rules are there is so that we know
who powerful figures are beholden to who
they may owe favors to
so that we can properly scrutinize and
check that they're not acting in the
interests of a privileged few
over and above the majority of people in
this country and at the moment we do not
have a prime minister in this country
that we can be confident is acting in
the interest of the british people
that's just unacceptable
and yet it seems to be if there if there
was any money
lent for this it seems to have come from
cchq doesn't it from the conservative
party itself in effect
we have absolutely no idea and that is
the problem that
days after these allegations surfaced we
still
haven't got any clarity from the
government from the prime minister
about what has gone on his press
secretary said that there was
a donation made a loan made he said that
there wasn't
somebody is lying here and we have to
have a government that is prepared to be
open and honest with the british people
and is prepared
to tell the truth over the last few
weeks what we've seen is a
mass of revelations about the very murky
financial dealings and cosy
relationships at the heart
of government we've got a situation
where the crown prince of saudi arabia
can pick up the phone to the prime
minister
and try and subvert processes that are
meant to protect football fans
in this country from the sort of
nightmare scenario that we went through
in wigan with the collapse of wigan
athletic and yet
we there are ordinary people as gordon
brown just said
on your programme who can't pick up the
phone to the prime minister who don't
have the health secretary's
mobile number who can't just text the
chancellor to advance their own
financial interests
it's one rule for them and one rule for
the rest of us
there's always going to be a case though
isn't there where where those people who
have
jobs of influence have access to
politicians i mean you know that
when the people who who come forward to
to anyone in a position of power you
have
better access than than than someone who
lives on worcester street
in barrow in furnace i'm not not sure
that's right actually i mean you know i
i have
social workers in my constituency deputy
had teachers in my constituency who have
my mobile number
and can pick up the phone when they need
something but i do agree
with the central point which is that
there will always be relationships in
government
there'll be relationships financial
relationships as well as
political relationships and power
relationships and that's why we have
these rules
about declaring donations about being
transparent and honest
so that people can be assured that there
isn't one rule for them
and another rule for the rest of us the
bottom line here
is integrity isn't it whether it's does
it have to be real integrity or
perceived integrity i think the bottom
line is
integrity it's honesty and it's
accountability and on
all three of those measures this prime
minister is falling
short we've got to see him come to the
house of commons make a statement
about this come clean about who
offered him money who he took money from
and what he owes them
in return why hasn't he declared these
donations
we've got to start to clean up this
sleaze at the heart of government
it's interesting when i was talking to
to gordon brown now he was
he was very careful not to suggest
sakira should follow
a different path on this but he was very
clear very clear within the interview
that
you know he thought this was yeah an
issue that that
was nowhere near as important to say
this the situation in india and the
global need
to tackle the pandemic you know the idea
that we need to now
take a global view on the pandemic i
mean
what do you take from that do do you
think you are pushing a domestic issue
when perhaps it is not the time to do so
no i think honesty trust and integrity
are absolutely vital
in a democracy otherwise the system
can't survive it collapses
so i don't see any any
um dissonance between wanting to focus
on the situation in india and wanting to
see the government step
up and wanting to see a government that
acts with integrity
that the british people can trust the
two things are synonymous they go
absolutely hand in hand that's why boris
johnson will face questions i'm sure at
prime minister's questions
later today about why he has behaved in
the dishonest
way that he has but it's also why
dominic raab the foreign secretary will
face questions from me later today
about why we're not doing more to tackle
what is now a global emergency no longer
a domestic crisis in india
and what do you want to see the foreign
secretary do in in terms of india
because we're talking of them surpassing
200 000 deaths i mean the likelihood is
it is
probably many times more that absolutely
i mean there are two million confirmed
cases in
india don't forget this is a country
that is 20
of the world's population this really is
now a global
emergency there's far more we can do we
send 600 pieces of surplus equipment
over
on sunday but we could do far more
particularly
the uk is a world leader in genome
sequencing and epidemiology
we can map and track variants of the
virus which will not only help
to get what is happening in india under
control but also help to make sure that
those variants don't spread to other
parts of the world
including the uk we need a proper plan
from the government about how they're
going to step up and tackle this global
emergency and that's what i'll be asking
dominic rob today i mean we have this
very strange situation where
we are providing them whether they're
buying the astrozenica vaccine but
effectively it cost it would seem and
yet
we seem to be buying five million doses
of vaccine
from india should we be doing that well
one of the questions i'll be asking
dominic rob today is do we have surplus
doses of the vaccine that we could use
to help
but the immediate problem in india is
they don't even have the staff
the medical staff to to administer the
vaccine they're desperately short of
oxygen of oxygen canisters of
ventilators
they've asked them us for that now do we
have surplus drugs that we could provide
because some of those drugs are going on
the black market for enormous
sums of money there is very very
immediate help that we could send we
need a global agreement on vaccine
surpluses
when we've got surplus doses and we will
have at some point
in this cycle we need to make sure that
we send them don't forget
a year ago we appealed for help to the
world because we were so woefully
unprepared
for this pandemic we had a prime
minister who'd just been released
from hospital himself suffering from
kovid and who stepped forward
it was the indian government who
released the export of
three million packets of paracetamol to
the uk because we'd run out
they stepped up for us in our hour of
need and we absolutely need to step up
for them i mean the transport secretary
telling us that
you know that we have sent over
equipment for for oxygen concentrators
you know we should pull oxygen supplies
out of the atmosphere
i mean that clearly is a step in the
right direction but you think do you
that there is actually a lot more we can
do
we sent 600 pieces of equipment it was
the right thing to do
but we haven't seen anywhere near the
peak of this crisis
in india experts predict that it's going
to be three weeks before we see
the peak of what's happening and we're
already seeing people turned away from
hospital
dying in hospital car parks crematoriums
overwhelmed people
burning bodies in their back gardens we
can't afford to step back now we should
be working with the united states who've
already
sent supplies over germany and other
countries in order to coordinate our
efforts and do
far far more in terms of that
coordination i mean
does the uk need to be seen as not just
a provider of aid but a
a broker of aid i think there's there
are diplomatic efforts that we could
deploy
to make sure that india is getting the
supplies that they need
particularly in the the region there's
more that we could do to prove
to ensure that supplies are sent very
very quickly
we also need to help india ramp up its
manufacturing capacity
it's been a huge debate about whether
more doses of the vaccine should be
donated
by wealthier countries who have lots of
those doses as you suggested
on order but the truth is if we end up
in a situation
where we're pitting india against
britain and countries against one
another
we're all going to lose to eradicate
this virus we need to eradicate it
everywhere and that means that we need
to ramp up our manufacturing
capability in countries like india and
the uk government could offer expertise
and help
to the indian government in order to
make sure that that happens lisa and
andy it's good to see you this morning
thank you